how many people have the opportunity to
be a world champion at anything we have
the opportunity to do something that no
one else does this isn't played anywhere
else in the world so yeah like it's
serious like we want to win
we're gonna watch unicycle football it's
football on unicycles we stick the NFL
rules as closely as possible since there
are a few exceptions goes riding a
unicycle we play five on five two
receivers a blocker a center and a
quarterback everything has to be done on
a wheel the second year foot touches the
ground you're done HT plays 14 games 56
regular season games total the wildcard
playoffs and playoffs and in the stupid
ball every Sunday some people have been
doing this for 10 years now my team the
black outs were undefeated and we're
gonna be playing the reigning champs the
herons bulldoze them over bulldoze this
game is very important because we want
to maintain our undefeated status
leading up to the Super Bowl they're
definitely going for us they're
practicing just for us I think that a
lot of times people come to this game
what shocks them is the level of play
we're crashing at 15 miles an hour it's
not a dope
some people get seriously injured most
people learn to ride unicycle because
they came and witnessed this event and
they're like I've got to do this once
you catch that first ball once you get
that first brush once you hear the crowd
scream your name once that's a feeling
you can't get anywhere else that's
almost like a religion Church says here
there's passion you know it's a show
it's a spectacle it's also a sport
I've cherished every minute of it can't
replace it anything there's nothing else
like it at all
Oh